and you said she taught you how to work
with actors she did how so well you know
working with Edith now doesn't seem
intimidating but then it was extremely
intimidating because here's an actress
whose first project was the pilot
episode of the guiding light when it was
on the radio in the 40s it may have been
early 30s but it was early early fifty
years of work who's worked in everything
from radio to television to most
recently at that time with David Fincher
it was terrifying for a college student
who hadn't graduated from college yet
and I was trying to figure out you know
how am I gonna work with this woman who
is far more experienced than me that
just happens to like the screenplay that
I wrote and so when she arrived you know
I had someone go pick her up at the
airport I booked her a nicest hotel in
town you know made sure she got the VIP
treatment as best a college student
could give and when she arrived to set I
was instantly disarmed because she knew
it she knew the script by heart it was
ten pages but she could recite every
single line because she had rehearsed
far before she arrived so the first
thing she taught me is that if you want
to work with an actor clarify your
vision at the onset and make sure that
you're going to work with someone who
takes that role just as seriously there
are a lot of actors that don't take
their roles seriously they don't read a
role and really try to dive into it and
so for me I'd have taught me first and
foremost find those people that really
care about what they're doing because
that's going to make your work better
it's not just a paycheck so the second
thing she taught while she's on set is
that while I may not have the experience
that she did she deferred those things
to me which empowered me as a director
to direct my college-aged crew to give
me respect which I thought was also very
important because at the time you know
in college were taking film classes
where people cycle around you know I
might direct one project and then run
the sound on another one shoot the next
one you're kind of learning different
skills and people don't take it
seriously
it's a class but because Edith Ivy who
has 50 years of experience who just
worked with David Fincher showed up
suddenly I had authority to do what I
wanted to do so I think those early
lessons for me were very formative and
kind of taught me that it doesn't matter
how much experience someone else on your
crew or someone else that you're active
that you're directing might have it only
matters that you as director have
authority over your set and that there's
a singular cohesive vision that everyone
can follow and respect
you